this program is brought to you by
Teachers College Columbia University
please visit us online at iTunes TC
columbia edu
Oh
first I'd like to express my heartfelt
gratitude for all the disallow this
conference to occur today so that
certainly includes reading my see
Teachers College the center of
educational outreach and innovation to
work of dr. gross barranca Alice vocal
Rick Agee slow and then of course I have
to stop there for the sake of time but
if you note in your program I have taken
the time to acknowledge everyone and if
I left out your name I abolished you
through apology so let's just begin this
morning I'm going to deliver the morning
address the opening address entitled
achieving cultural competence acquiring
requisite knowledge attitudes and skills
for an evidence-based revolution
bringing equity in health to all that's
it so let's start with talking about
what is cultural competence nunez and
robertson explain the cultural
competence represents the ability of
healthcare providers or those of us here
were health educators or nurses or
psychologists or counselors or pastoral
counselors all of us acquiring the
ability to interact with anyone who's
different from ourselves in such a way
that we are effective and so we can see
that we're talking about those
differences they certainly range from
everything for race religion ethnicity
to language socioeconomic status sexual
orientation disabilities etc we're
talking about knowledge attitudes and
skills and of course the idea is that
it's a process to
higher these requisites knowledge
attitude and skill cultural competencies
and then we can look at the definition
also offered where we're talking about a
set of behaviors ok so imagine that we
have to put whatever it is that we go
whatever attitudes have to be into
action and so here we can talk about
behaviors but we can also talk about
policies and in addition we recognize
that cultural competence can also be
something that in the ideal situation
characterizes our organizations and also
our health professions the organizations
to which you belong the goal is that we
are able to work effectively in
cross-cultural situations where there's
a different cultural background between
you as the provider the researcher the
teacher and those with whom you are
interacting and so the result ends up
being a great broad training mission and
the idea is that whether we're talking
about policymakers administrators
organizational leaders or teachers the
idea is that they all can also be
assessed regarding where they are in
this process they can be assessed for
the level of organizational or the level
of individual cultural or multicultural
competence it's all see later that we
can specifically approach this through
the notion of stages of change drawing
upon the work of precocity chlamydia
Mercedes a change from the
transtheoretical model so let's say to
change our unit as individual what
states are change is your organization
what about your your place of employment
can we see the vet organization or that
you are actually in an action seriously
to acquire me the requisite level of
cultural competence or might you feel as
though your organization is new thinking
of these things we would certainly hope
that in this day age the organization's
have really moved toward taking action
so we return for training models well
the field of psychology certainly has
provided us been a lot because they have
certainly taken to achieve the mission
of training individuals and
multicultural competence as a matter of
fact here at Teachers College we
recently had the annual winter round
table and we could acknowledge some of
those individuals who have contributed
to a very large body of knowledge
regarding everything from covert forms
of racism and oppression I've talked
about invisible violence in my own work
and others have talked about racial
microaggressions going back to the
original work of Chester Pierce and so
we see but Darrell being sued is
contributed by taking the work of
Chester Pierce and also some of the work
of my mentor dr. AJ Franklin who's now
at the Boston and he's been able to
recently in 2007 article American
psychologist expand and build on that
foundation it's very important that we
all realize that he has built on that
foundation because ready nor deny that
july two thousand seven american
psychologist article doesn't have a
reference to the work of chester p.m.
strange in franklin so we all want to
memorize the roots of the work in the
area of facial microaggression and
recognize the predecessors who preceded
our Darryl Mason and lay a foundation
for his 2070 work so the idea is that
there's a large body of work and so
given this training machine we're to be
also occurring for guidance be on their
own Department of counseling psychology
your teachers college and may authors
there for their accrediting agencies
there are those days
that set standards for example the
Association of American Medical Colleges
liaison committee of medical education
of course we can't forget the Institute
mess and blue million listen I think
without report and so we can turn to the
amount of the Association of American
Medical Colleges and their definition of
cultural competence and again we see a
recurring theme in terms of the
attention paid to behaviors and of
course knowledge attitudes and policies
and of course the focus one that
actually happens in cross-cultural
situations there are also a related
goals and so a related goal is that the
curriculum in medical school and by
expansion the curriculum that we all
experience through our education we are
teaching in the ideal situation we
follow the standards set by the aamc and
that is that we just saw impact on
education in curriculum about cultural
competence that we actually integrated
into the curriculum and this is a very
old fundamental concept and if we have
to actually identify the percentage of
universities and colleges that have
actually infused it or integrated
cultural competence across the
curriculum we might not feel that happy
to be met analysis but it's an age is it
an era of responsibility and we're
hoping the old young here represent the
future I'm going to integrating that
curriculum that that sense of cultural
competence across the brave one that we
look out the audience and we recognize
dr. Nicholas krauskopf we recognize dr.
charles arable our newest graduates from
teachers college who are now teaching
the community system and with hope we
aspire to the vision that the day will
come because they cultural
it's truly not an add-on but integrated
into the curriculum there are also
related goals that I give in this
institutional leadership and support
that the plan and the vision of
integrating cultural competence across
the curriculum and even having
experiential opportunities for
individuals who acquire the skills
practice the recommended set of
behaviors that it's really critical that
that leadership comes from the top it's
the president they said me it's the
administration that saying we value this
we need our faculty and our students to
basically move in that direction from
making sure that the curriculum is
revised in such a way that training and
cultural competence is at the center and
we can turn to the work of Betancourt in
this associates and we're just so
excited because of 1120 we're going to
actually hear dr. Joseph been where tell
us his latest vision regarding racial
ethnic disparities and cross-cultural
care but so many of us in doing over
research come across the very important
work contributions of betancourt and his
associates and so here we see the
concept of actually being a strategy and
the idea that it could actually improve
healthcare the idea that cooling
competence is at the core of creating
the new healthcare system we're all
excited that we see the possibilities of
a new healthcare system actually being
bought fourth of the new administration
the administration of President Barack
Obama what's going to be key is cultural
competence and so we envision all of you
here as some of the future national and
global leaders who can ensure that the
new healthcare system in terms of what
you are doing of what you're treating
others to do is going to reflect at the
core the importance of cultural
competence as a strategy to improve
healthcare in addition we can also
recognize through some of the interviews
and
groups that that in court reports on
that this associates the way in which
those experts in the field really see a
link between cultural competence and
health disparities so that if we're
going to move for the goal of equity in
health for all and eliminate ethnic and
racial health disparities or health
disparities of all significant groups
whether it's disability abled disabled
whether it's those among a particular
sexual orientation and those who are
heterosexual people be rates of HIV AIDS
and we're talking about those between
blacks and whites aesthetics autumn
autumn on geographic regions the idea is
that what's he to addressing that
situation is cultural competence by the
slides not enough there's also consensus
that we have to do much more that we
have to recognize that there are
multiple factors and causes and that
cultural competence alone is
insufficient to address those problems
in addition what emerges from
associations that are involved in
ensuring that whole competence is a part
of the curriculum what happens is that I
typically we talk about standards that
their info and accreditation standards
or shredded or or training standards and
so we can look for example to an
excellent example in the aamc and how
they actually codified cultural
competencies specifically for knowledge
specifically for attitudes beliefs and
skills those behaviors that we enact and
they have basically created the total
call the tac the T acct and they have
given us a guy from medical schools
they're cleaning our medical doctors and
the idea is that battle schools can take
these guidelines and see how they could
integrate you there
those activities that was sure that
people are trained that the medical
doctors in training receive what they
need in line with these competencies so
now we can turn to what we're doing here
at Teachers College and as you saw from
the program many of the people in the
audience are fellows with the research
group of disparities and health are GTH
something that I direct you see the
symbol of the research group on the
program and you can see the way English
we're talking about at the core of our
mission shifting from equity in health
equity health and I'm going to lab rate
on that we're also very much foster the
21st century global civil rights
movement for equity and health for all
so that is a symbol that very simply
shows how we're crossing out with the
red because symbol of the old paradigm a
over B which represents hierarchical
domination oppression home base of
thinking and behaving and we want to
move toward or foster not in
hierarchical equality are all equal new
ways of thinking acting in the world so
we're responding also to a call that's
been put out for this global movement
whether we look at the work of
congressional black caucus leader domick
Christian Christensen who noted that
health disparities RV civil rights issue
of the 21st century are we can turn into
the leader of our civil rights movement
dr. Bob Luther King jr. and turned to
his quote he said of all the forms of
inequality injustice in health is the
most shocking and the most inhumane now
amount of thing that we're doing here
Teachers College through the research
group of asperities and help is that
recruiting global leaders to work
alongside community members as they self
determined and sustaining their
communities own health and so we have
individuals in this audience right now
we've traveled to Togo Africa Haiti
Jamaica India Kenya Africa and they
represent this mission of global
leadership training and made by others
to join the research Rufus fellows and
also to join what we also started called
global help help standing for a health
education leadership program and we see
ourselves as watching a new
transdisciplinary field of equity in
health and so there are some mechanisms
for training these global leaders and
promoting a new field of equity and
health so that you perhaps have heard
about the certificate and health
disparities reduction the way that we're
using online education to have a
far-reaching impact we're also played
online and a degree so that we can also
do that in addition we're shifting the
discourse but in this error we seem to
talk about what we want health equity
for all isn't what we do not want health
this very so that's part of the
rationale that is shipped and so we also
are shifting the paradigm the guiding
paradigm are guiding personal paradigms
the paradigms that itis it our
professions in our work in terms of our
identities we're shooting from the old
paradigm symbolized by a over B to the
new paradigm and we feel that the new
paradigm presents the conditions for
social justice freedom liberty the
pursuit of happiness so weirdly find
such preparation for being a global
leader because we're putting at the core
of our work here valuing such
preparation so we can turn into multiple
sources in search of that prep
in search of the ideal training we could
even consider the words soak in january
twentieth on the ball by our new
president barack obama and please
examine his words we see what we can
call that new paradigm language so what
are some examples of that new paradigm
language here talking about all are
equal all are free and all deserve a
chance to pursue their full measure of
happiness other new paranoid words that
we saw the extent to ish just as i
mentioned we're training old leaders to
work alongside community members here we
see President Obama speaking of a pledge
to other nations to work alongside you
not that old paradigm of a over B where
we seek to tell you what to do or impose
upon you our models but instead to work
alongside you to make your farms
flourish and let clean waters flow not
occur on to the high bluff low as we saw
is not just a master drummer but someone
who is dedicated right now to mean a
water project a clean-water project to
roll unity and gun to nourish our bodies
and feed hungry lines to also bring
micro financing projects allow women to
grow food to feed their families to the
entire communities so the idea is that
we cannot be indifferent to suffering
outside our borders looking be consuming
the world's resources and help regard to
eat our gasoline addiction as he saw
symbolized Leonato's playing thanks o
heart was that beautiful coping the
things
the part 1 keep moving forward the idea
that the shopping how many of us don't
shop like we used to okay for some
people that's the problem but for others
of my suspicions successive were hoping
they're making it through but the idea
is that we cannot consume not only
resources but perhaps we cannot afford
to have that credit card debt that you
had so the world has changed an English
change with it and the things fall apart
even when things in the ashes that's
when the Phoenix can rise from the ashes
so consider our new paradigm words and
trends for example landmark education
there's a landmark forum for teens for
young people there's an advanced course
there's a self expression leadership
program and so the many of you in here
who heard me back in two thousand I talk
about my experience and my sense of
urgency that this was an education for
living that you could get three days and
I highly recommended it and then going
on to the Advanced Course and
self-expression leadership program to be
challenged to create a possibility for
your transformational fai create I
created I am a lone leader training
other global leaders to assist to work
almost like movies and he coming in
power to self-determine is the standard
on health house 2005 am I even drew a
symbol of my project in the self
expression leadership program and I've
had a model linking lies across the
Atlantic and let me hold but I you a
little book of hands that
class like this in 2005 in 2008 my
fellows 788 one came up with that symbol
and I didn't even realize it till about
a week ago so the idea is that when you
create a possibility for something and
you draw and you envision that related
in an era when this really helps seems
to manifest and that were literally
creating their own reality and so
landmark is powerful and giving you an
opportunity to create their own
possibility of transformation and though
I am the most powerful words you could
use and creating that if she would like
to bring forth I am the possibility I
and being so that's an invitation for
you and their other new paradigm workers
and friends so you have heard the secret
a dream have you heard the secret have
you seen the DVD I recently read the
book and I realize oh there's nothing
like getting the book so I recommend
that everybody send twenty dollars in
read the book so that you can see but
Rhonda Byrne in 2006 has given us the
law of attraction that your thoughts are
magnetic okay so here we are talking
about cultural competence education
we're talking about watching the new
field of equity in health we're talking
about training global leaders but is
willing this is in the new paradigm it's
not my real parents in the old paradigm
you basically sit and be smooth in an
education yes yes given that education
fine I just have to be passive yes
position give me the prescription tell
me what to do how do I take it the new
paradigm it doesn't work like that other
new paradigm words that President Obama
spoke it's a new era of responsibility
and so you gotta take responsibility for
your thoughts what are your thoughts are
you thinking this is going to be a very
slow process oh this is going to be
slow process oh this is going to be a
very slow process guess what it's going
to be a very slow process oh I am going
to do symc I can't do XY and z I'm going
to do next time T I can't do XY and z
well guess what you're seeing option
messages if they'd lay track things that
are on the same frequency so you're a
human transmission tower you can submit
whatever that word is and create some
girl and so how do we take
responsibility for our own thoughts
please do not be shy at this moment okay
I told you oh different angle so what
are my thoughts these are questions i
invite you to ask yourself come back it
went back lights out please these are
the things I asked you to ask yourself
what are your thoughts what are you
transmitting okay what are you talking
to your life and what might you be
visualizing and acting as in taxes if
you already have something and then
there's also other new paradigm words
and trends we can turn into of us this
was over slow club selection and we
could all go save her it's obsession for
almost two thousand eight it actually
offering free online curriculum that you
could access and so the idea is that
imagine the words of a our total your
entire life generally ultimately
consists of the steps you are taking at
this moment there's only this step and
so give it your full attention to learn
to read and to be fully present in the
here and now not fearful I'm gonna lose
a job not thinking listing more about
this whole confidence stuff about mega
class money without me at breakfast or
those XY
humber feeling them a note to be fully
present in here now and the concept an
inner alignment with the present moment
opens your consciousness and brings into
alignment with the whole of which this
present moment is an integral part
imagine that we have to take
responsibility for a toll calls eco
impaired its destruction the idea that
we have to become conscious participants
in the creation of form it is not legal
creating but Universal told us that
creates us roaming that the active
region may involve the highest level of
energy quite intense that it's not hard
work it's not stressful and I would ever
refueling imagine whenever you're
feeling stressed out or sense of
struggle the idea of the ego is present
if we encounter a negative obstacle or
something if you're feeling stressed off
our egos inactivated any may have to i'm
going to try and break it down in just
two minutes but the idea is that the
stronger the ego the shorter the sense
of separateness suiting people so we're
talking about bringing equity help the
whole and equality if I'm walking around
feeling like oh that's exclude those
people oh that's excluded those people
we did invite those people but if they
are inclusive instead oh but we are
exclusive when we're separated oh my
country my religion my shoes are better
than her she's my car is better than his
car my country's superior to your
country my language is better than your
language my species is superior to your
species but the idea instead that we
like to attain is a situation
we are fully conscious of how our seat
of consciousness is helping to create
the world and so can you be fully
present in here enamel and overcome any
ego dysfunction that can contribute to
that sense of self earnest I'm separate
from I'm better than I'm above we are
exclusive we don't inviting the superior
to my country is better my religion is
there but not that sense of oneness with
all of humanity and then we can also
turn to a book that we have in the back
tigre speaks lessons for living in
harmony so long as you can see is great
busy and the idea is that some of the
key concepts involve unity
interdependence the concept what if next
one affects all and we have just gotten
a mobile estimate is that what's
happening my economy effects of global
economy and so what affects one affects
all because of consciousness and
awareness that's a part of this new
paradigm and it's important for us also
to realize that a community experience
such as a conference as a temporary
community or when you cook a large
family meal that you are actually
creating in that community a healing
experience and so it turns out that this
multi really speaks at some of those
core values constitute an ancient
africanism tigre is actually um an
African angel who came forth from the
hulu creation as a spark of light with
the angelic host now how old is
teetering Tigre let's list the very
first communities to stand upright in
Africa tecum eggs with the very first
duty to stand upright
so this is pretty ancient so when we
talk about spirituality or we talk about
new place spirituality we're talking
about what is ancient and old and
aggregate and that wisdom has been
infused into the HIV AIDS education
training manual as the values that guide
that training that when you have a buddy
in your training it's about unity it's
about interdependence it's about what
affects one affects all it's about when
you come 20 minutes late to training if
we're trying to get this training done
on mountain in Ghana in a village in
Sierra Leone in the middle of three
hurricanes in Haiti in August 2008 we
need you to be on time the next one
affects all okay so there's a
consciousness that is a part of the
creation training manual and then
there's some of the latest information
that just came forth recently from T
today SOT recent you realize the Libra
singing hair it's the dawning of the Age
of Aquarius so you don't be proof of
that because you're younger and that's
why we believe you listening down that
it's now angel babies it has arrived
it's been here about four or five weeks
now and what it means is that what you
speak will benefit very quickly so you
say I want a new lover it's like Memphis
right if you say I am a global leader
Trinamool leaders it make
very quickly 30 children my door Oh
Wallace I wanted I'm gonna be in your
project I want to draw the doctor
program ok but don't cancel out what you
call forth by saying Oh star take a very
long time I'll begin any money come on
ease back Oh nobody's gonna have to
grant funding for us oh no I can't do it
or I don't want to give up football
season so I'm not going to do it so pay
attention to your language because once
you say the benefits very quickly and in
addition to what you feel because again
if I've been hearing down center-aligned
what I feel is a guy if it feels good do
if it feels bad warning warning warning
warning you're thinking something
countdown today it is manifestation your
transmission tower you're feeling bad
you're thinking something bad you're
thinking I would do well this car has an
exam you're thinking I'm not going to do
well to start as an exam anxiety anxiety
heart palpitations and sariah
dysfunction collapses whole part or
you're thinking I am constantly balance
I am calm certain balance I am moving
forward I am achieving at my highest
potential and so some of the tools that
we use to be searchable disparities in
health also available today is the few
copies to help launch this new field of
equity in health and then what we're
giving away free today is the Journal of
equity in health that's available on the
back they'll go in front right on before
criminy and this is our tool to
collectively launch and sustain the new
zeal of equity in health and then we
have the hiv/aids for
asia training manual we're Billy local
and global capacity again I mentioned
Sierra Leone in 2005 were dr. Richard
combat into training and then do 10 in
2006 nomograms mom in Ghana directed at
recurrent training and now we're
disseminating this home free through
global health and then we have our
fellows who are adapting it so that it's
culturally appropriate you're going to
hear about those presentations actually
glad them going to togos India featured
speaker on Saturday and then for the
remainder of that night min experiential
hear from people who went to India Kenya
and Jamaica and i'll present with
shamini caster din and haiti and so what
kind of research mediation beyond
evaluating this hiv/aids for education
curriculum wish as she's going to
present more data as did the operation
calamari how this is emerging as an
evidence-based approach in terms of
increasing knowledge at citygate levels
so we're adapting it and so what else
will be doing as an evidence-based
approach and how is it consistent with
current trends in individuals and
organizations toward achieving cultural
competence we have any D dissertations
here and so we have the mercury on Mars
and may you know her love her so her
dissertation was in coming medical
students perceptions of knowledge
attitudes and skills regarding crosswalk
medical education and together we
develop the free medical education
student survey across cultural training
issues if you recall i talked about the
AFC and their cultural competencies and
so we basically took that cool and turn
those competencies in two items on a
survey so that medical students could
rate how important do they think it is
they get this
medical education and this was the
oldest before they started medical
school and how would they make
themselves when they're coming into
medical school training in terms of
these competencies and in addition we
now have Shana Lassiter who in research
seminar sent us here at the dental
school why don't we basically do this
dissertation but in transcendental
school curriculum and so she's looking
at culture compensate training in dental
education and implications for the
elimination of oral health disparities
results from a quantitative and
qualitative investigation and she's
presenting she initiates going to be a
post-recession but if you know dr.
Glinda claire had a family emergency
involving the illness with machado and i
told Shannon Shannon you have of that
presentation on a flash drive and so
she's ready to go that's what we placed
it as is Shannon mumbling in the back
there who's going to talk about her work
in her program and so Maria marzan ended
up being a 67 item student survey and
you can see the areas that that were
perfectly aligned with the AFC cultural
competencies by appointed by her types
of skills were created so this warm a
for the self-rating the form be for how
they made it what they wanted in their
medical education how important it was
to them and it was administered here in
New York City to medical students and
all these people are they start their
education and just sample items you know
about identifying position bias there
typing things of that sort and so what
was looked at also the social
desirability now if you think about
medical students or graduate students or
just students period have you hear that
concept of brown-nosing yeah okay so we
complete our survey that will students
might be
kind of good at saying what you want to
hear and so it's really important to
always be a professor that we created
then the soldiers are building scale so
we can see well how high are you on that
desire to save other people water or to
get a desirable a socially desirable
response and also we wanted to know what
about people because you know
increasingly a lot of undergraduates are
getting cultural competency training or
hours of education and something you
wanted to also look at to what extent do
classroom hours in fact that self rating
of how folks accompany are you starting
medical school and also might impact how
gray what's important when you go to
school and so we looked at predictors
and relationships I'll turned out that
the scale is a really nice scale it's
got good internal consistency both for
the form that deals with a self-rating
and the form that deals with the
importance in your education but your
value and this particular tool is now
really emerging as an excellent tool for
use if you use in baseline assessment
and it also could be used to say well
now that this medical student has been
exposed to three or four years of
medical education do we see any change
in their rating of cultural competence
so what we found was that the higher the
social desirability skills scores the
higher they made it themselves okay so
interesting and then we also found some
of the relationship there there is
nothing there for how they be that their
school or what they wanted inner edge
occation and there were other
relationships that were found between
having more classroom hours and cultural
competence of diversity training more
prior education the area the morning had
prior to medical school a higher your
self ratings in terms of your cultural
competence in the areas of knowledge
skills and attitudes the leaves and so
and you've also going to be more
that your medical education covered
these these kind of things this cultural
competence training if you already have
some education so now we can really see
how we talk about infusing cultural
competency training across the
curriculum you can now see how the
parade is then it starts with our
freshmen who are going to college that
they get something that's infused across
the curriculum through their freshman
and sophomore junior senior years
because of those individuals decide to
go into the health care professions
whether it's inedible school nursing
health education we can be it's likely
that we're going to value many more
they're going to come to a place like
Teachers College expecting on the
graduate level that professors are doing
with English krauskopf is doing a
kingsborough that he's talking about
issues of cultural competence and
cultural sensitivity and they are also
likely to just to be loving people
because they work with him okay so what
are some of the best predictors of a
higher self rated of overall cultural
competence well the more prior exception
hours and cultural competence training
had higher income tend to be and you
take it to to not be more the US and
there were there was quite a number of
individuals who were you know of course
from various places for suing their
medical education during the United
States and the best predictors for a
higher form be numbers higher vaiting of
the importance of cultural confidence
trading in the upcoming medical
education well those tended to be women
they valued this more in your education
they were older and they have more prior
exception hours in home confidence so
this makes the point that I made earlier
and we're hoping certainly that there
are other positive trends that are going
to expand such as residency programs
following the Accreditation Council of
graduate medical education and the
standards that they're setting for
cultural competence trained and how they
are increasingly putting
emphasis upon this of course Institute
of Medicine has recommended
cross-cultural curricula Tihar between
the clinicians from the undergraduate
level through continuing medical
education so even if individuals were
certainly coming you're already having
physicians are coming to a conference
like this and our situation in the ideal
situation we were offering CMEs that
that's what's really value pack see
that's what's accepted in this new era
of responsibility what are you doing
because even if your current
undergraduate or graduate education has
not integrated and infused cultural
competence training across the
curriculum and this new error
responsibility is up to you to ensure
that you're doing the reading that
you're doing the research to make sure
that you are acquiring to come to
conferences where they're also a
workshop components so you can acquire
not only the knowledge but also acquire
the skills and have experiential
opportunities to really acquire
behaviors that are consistent with
cultural competence so as you can see
this it'll be moving into the mainstream
of healthcare and we're excited about
that now we can also talk a little bit
about some of the implications for
research and other things and I
emphasize in teaching is how we not only
have to look at the prevalence because
you know a lot of researchers with the
prevalence of a disease enter to your
problem behavioral often does it occur
but it's the rate which it occurs how
often do people experience what's the
current rate of HIV of diabetes etc etc
and as it turns out you can also look at
the prevalence of maladaptive and
adaptive coach responses and that we can
focus in particular applaud adaptive
strengths and response to stress okay so
the idea is that we may find that there
are examples of adaptive coping an
individual with strength and muscle
for example where are the communities
where are the families where are the
churches and the moss and the synagogues
that have come up with strategies for
those members in their congregations or
communities or family's amazing homework
ish foreclosures okay so maybe this is
an idea that Mercedes had in class a
couple of weeks ago we were talking
about implications of some of these
things and Mercedes said well yeah
that's a good idea we def we have
churches coming up with strategies to
assist families going through
foreclosure for example in other words
the reality is that there are innovative
creative things that are going on across
the nation given the economic stress and
something ideas what are some of the
adaptive coping responses and how might
we identify them and then how might we
encourage others to replicate those
models of taking responsibility in this
soup era of responsibility and self
determining not only their own health
with their economic health in addition
to their spiritual health for example so
it's about focusing on strength and
resilience and what works what
constitutes an adaptive coping strategy
for those facing certain kinds of stress
in the larger social contract because as
we know health disparities and
eliminating them has everything to do
with not only focusing on how we can
improve individual level coping but
fluency from the larger social context
it's all about understanding the social
determinants the social environmental
determinants of disparities and so we
also now turn and say what constitutes
an adaptive response to diversity of
difference on our hearts okay and what
isn't it but somehow that active
response when were working for our
school people let's just quickly role
model some maladaptive responses oh I
hate these clients they stink they're
dirty can you please rate and go out to
lunch oh I hate this job
okay all those people Oh sequel all
they're thieves they're criminals those
people so the idea is that we also want
to avoid research we were just comparing
as a researcher it can be maladaptive
just to all and all on my researches
comparing blacks and whites blacks and
whites long ago it was recommended that
it's not about a relative status of one
group to another it's not enough to
compare groups but really to understand
how many hope and drive in a social
group of context that to identify those
coping strategies it's critical and then
we have to understand that achieving
cooking competence is a process of
journey what do we need and so there's a
rationale for this equity in health
vision there's a rationale for a
cultural competence approps there's a
rationale for an evidence-based approach
and so we might be called for example of
the video that was released last year
unnatural causes the idea that a polity
is actually making us sick of course I
like say can't cancel okay well cuz
we're talking about how global leaders
can work along so I community members
and empower them to self-determine their
own else we want to focus on that but
this is a reality but the idea is that
what arises from that is how social
justice right to help those things
become a part of our discourse partly
because of that video last year and a
call for a new global civil rights
movement for equity in health and all
and recognizing that it's driven by
forces 13 forces have been identified in
the volume and I'm not going to go
through all of these we've already
talked about the paradigm shift we
surely talk about the drive for cultural
competence and cultural appropriateness
and I'm going to give you a preview of
tomorrow's moines panel by just saying
that it's so important that we
understand that what's happening in the
social context also involves this crisis
involving a car so
that's closely tied to addiction and the
HIV HIV AIDS epidemic so I won't go
through all this it's a common reality
that we're facing a crisis involving our
newest prison industrial complex that
large numbers are incarcerated that
these these statistics are really quite
shocking that were leading the world in
incarceration and then certainly there's
the you that racism has been a part of
this the past 30 years of high levels of
imprisonment and in addition we can also
recognize that where we need to figure
out what to do with those who are
returning to the community so there's an
urgent issue we've all involving the
entry so we're going to have a panel and
community forum tomorrow that will deal
with those issues we're hopeful though
because we're also perhaps about to see
New York's a mandatory minimum sentences
a turned-over peeled and so we're very
hopeful about that and we're going to
have fully love give us his you so we're
seeing some of his views about hiv/aids
epidemic incarceration crisis the whole
see what's his current thinking and
he'll start us off tomorrow before we
have that particular panel discussion
now my challenge to you is very simple
that we need to learn adaptive responses
I will model the maladaptive respond I
don't know where those clients those
criminals those drug addicts those
people separate separate eagle
dysfunction ego dysfunction I'm superior
I'm separate from them I'm superior to
them I'm separated from them but we need
to learn adaptively to a new set of
abc's affected responses hepa the--
respect those are the affective
responses that are ideal behavioral
responses of basically providing
standard services at the very highest
level not discriminating at all in our
behavior no stereotyping know somehow
referring white males from work Alaska
peas and black males that we literally
already HUP handle response
that show that we are the embodiment of
equal of treating others as though they
are equal as though we are not separate
or superior to them and cognitive or
slices also need to be adaptive
cognitive responses of thinking things
such as well certainly not thinking the
thoughts of I'm better than but instead
coming from this new paradigm of
equality so in this way I offer you the
charge for this conference which is that
you contemplate these centuries you want
to be a global leader who something to
learn these kind of adaptive responses
and the question becomes who are you are
you someone who's going to execute these
adaptive responses okay who are you are
you someone who can express acceptance
respect and empathy and then finally I'm
also talking about something that's
called the three arms and in terms of
these three yards they are to be
responsible reliable and relaxed and so
I'm asking that you consider this
particular affirmation to be responsible
reliable in this movement to bring about
little equity for all I am who I say I
am I do what I say I'm going to do if I
ever fail to be or do what I said I look
I apologize and we commit and the
affirmation that people taking the
comprehensive exam should be doing daily
and before they do anything associated
with their dissertation and that all of
us should do so we could be centered and
aligned I am calm centered in bounds and
with that giving you the new three hours
giving you the a re giving you the ABCs
I'm going to be who I said I would be
and in one time or close to it thank you
so much
without me to take a break and come back
in 15 minutes and here would we are so
excited about and that's the keynote
address of down reduces that in court so
please exactly 15 minutes
the preceding program was brought to you
by Teachers College Columbia University
please visit us online at iTunes TC
columbia edu